he is a man who lost seven weeks ago
could have believed Rishi sunak's chance
would come again so soon
in the summer he failed to convince a
membership selling a tough message that
came to pass the lights on the economy
are flashing red and the root cause is
inflation his allies say he's a serious
man for a serious time Mark Harper was
the very first MP to publicly back him
he's got a meticulous attention to
detail what's incredibly hard if I was a
member of the public and I'm looking at
the things I'm worried about I want
someone who's serious
hard-working competent and focused on
getting things right for their benefit
ball in Southampton the son of a GP and
pharmacist an unashamed Star Wars fan at
Winchester scholar Rishi sunak was Keen
to pitch himself as a Great British
success story in my family gave me
opportunities they could only dream of
after graduating he went straight to
Goldman Sachs and married into one of
India's richest families
he only joined parliament in 2015. you
work with Rishi sunak when he was a
junior Minister what's he like to work
with he's opening words to me in bed
when I was like a head of columns he
said I don't think I'm going to be very
happy with me he said I'm not not really
interested in making a name for myself
in the media
and I thought well what what a healthy
and well-adjusted human being this is I
mean I liked him from the get-go what I
did see I found uh enormously impressive
but it was as the covid chancellor that
Rishi sunak was propelled into public
Consciousness we will support incomes we
will support businesses
and we will help you protect your loved
ones
we will do whatever it takes
from polling as one of the most popular
politicians in the country in April his
political career was on the brink of
collapse in the space of a week Rishi
sunak was forced to defend his wife's
nondon tax status and find for breaking
covid rules it was an incredible
comeback but Rishi sunak inherits an
extraordinary entry the shadow of covert
hanging over the economy combined with
this trusses disastrous economic
policies and political problems too he
may have got the backing of most MPS but
some still see him as a man who took
down Boris Johnson
Boris Johnson couldn't block the former
Chancellor's path to power this time at
the second time of asking seven years
after becoming an MP Rishi sunak is
prime minister he'll be a different
leader from his two predecessors but
that doesn't mean he can heal the party
or the country Ali Ford SKU Sky News
Westminster